okay about 10 15 years ago i taught some
eighth graders it's coming up on
thanksgiving holiday and we just
finished doing newtonian mechanics and
basic physics and we're about to start
on thermodynamics so i say ah i know
what to do here's your homework over
thanksgiving make a graph of the
temperature of a turkey
on thanksgiving day you know from
morning to afternoon you know put the
units down you know temperature make
sure you've got units well okay
the students are in america thanksgiving
is an american holiday turkeys are north
american birds all the same it would be
nice if you use celsius but if you have
to okay meanwhile there's students in my
class and i'm telling them okay i know
some of you are vegetarians and you
don't even have turkeys some of you
don't celebrate thanksgiving some of you
are going to be traveling some you know
i don't even have any thermometers to
give you doing science means you're
going to figure this out and do the
experiment you're going to find your own
equipment if you don't have a turkey
around
measure the temperature of lasagna
or measure the temperature of
xiaomian just
give me a graph
across time and temperature
really what i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to say oh we're going to study a
little bit about thermodynamics coming
up we finished newtonian mechanics
upcoming is
how does
heat flow you know
and this leads into some truly wonderful
partial differential equations and
ingredients and and for a heat flow but
of course i'm not going to go there i
just want them to realize that heat
moves from cold you know there's a heat
flow
that never goes from cold to hot it
always goes from hot to cold that's
motivating me and my usual thing with
homework is if you hand it in you get an
a
if you don't have it in
you get an f hand this out give them
your name oven temperature and the
temperature make sure you give me units
come monday after thanksgiving comes
30 different
things 30 different reports i get them
let's start look at them immediately
it's obvious who copied from who it's
right away obvious who just you know
copied somebody else's
some of the graphs you're seeing look
like this people have scribbled things
at
where they put one dot over here at
70 degrees f one dot over here at the
oven temperature of
of
whatever they whatever their mom set it
to 350 degrees fahrenheit drew a
straight line between there
and this was like 9 00 a.m
this is 3 p.m you know they just said oh
straight line like this others you saw a
graph that went like
oh here's a dot here dot here all went
up down there
you could then
you know even though the even though the
oven temperature was set to 350 it never
got much above
oh
160 or so degrees fahrenheit other
students did it in celsius
one
one kid wrote every used kelvin in the
ideal world
there would be a phase change from
a frozen turkey across
and then through boiling and up higher
but you know in fact we're going to stay
in this region here and really the slope
of this line
tells us about the foray heat equation
that says the gradient
of
temperature determines how fast heat
flows across it it's parents night and
parents come in the evening and want to
know how how's my kid doing in class and
i've describe the experiments that we're
doing and what their kids are doing in
school and it's it's way fun and
afterwards
three parents two moms and a dad come up
to me separately and they say
that thing with it with the thanksgiving
experiment
was wonderful for my kid because it's
the first
time
that my kid
came into the kitchen on thanksgiving
over and over and over again every half
hour my my son would open the oven door
put a
thermometer in the turkey measure the
temperature write it down add a dot to
the graph and keep going like this it's
the first time
my kids
spent
spent time in the kitchen on
thanksgiving and that parents were
delighted
and i thought yeah you know it's so
but the coolest thing the coolest
the warmest thing of all
was one
one of my students
took took this seriously and
graphed the temperature of
eight of the turkey on thanksgiving and
ended up with a graph rather than going
up across the day
rather than you know
going along there
this
this student
made a
handed in a graph
where from morning
to evening
the temperature
remained exactly the same
if i remember right she wrote down 104
degrees
and i looked at it and i asked why is
the temperature the same she says
it's a live turkey
where did she stick the thermometer
i had no idea
you know she completely slammed dunked
me absolute you know there's there's
somebody
who gets an e plus added
if you enjoyed this video you're the
sort of person who likes to think a bit
outside the box then i think you're
really gonna like brilliant this is a
website of puzzles and courses and all
sorts of problems that help change the
way you think they kind of i guess they
kind of make you a smarter person let's
have a look at what's on the side at the
moment here are some daily challenges i
really enjoy these they're good fun kind
of like a you know a puzzle of the day i
guess
stuck in a tight spot what's the square
side let's have a look at courses today
click up here so many courses available
on brilliant i mean i could pick any of
these but let's have a look at
mathematical fundamentals
cryptograms
did you in place of b would make this
sum true i reckon that's going to be a
what do you reckon a 5
that was a pretty easy one
what about this one what are you going
to put there for zed to make that true
look i'm not going to do all of it this
is just a tiny tiny taste there's so
much to see on brilliant go and have a
look at the site now you can have a look
at it for free there's all sorts of
stuff you can do but if you want to sign
up for the premium version and get
access to everything you get 20 off that
if you go to brilliant.org
number five that's brilliant.org number
five for that 20 off seriously you
should have a look at this it's an
amazing resource and our thanks to
brilliant for supporting this episode
[Music]